okay hi everyone uh thank you for having
me here Mark um so today I'm going to
talk about uh some of the work that I
did uh during my PhD in marks lab here
at Stanford um and my dissertation was
titled getting a gecko grip surface
confirmation for dry adhesion assisted
robot body
grasping so I will start first by um
giving some context uh on the topic of
surface confirmation how to sort of wrap
around conform to something and it's
it's a thing that we see in nature quite
a bit uh a lot of animals when they're
trying to Traverse their terrain you'll
see they will have you know either
they're wrapping around a branch or or
or something that they're trying to
maneuver over um and even when we handle
tools or different things in our
day-to-day you always see that we're
trying to have these enveloping grasps
we're trying to really take advantage of
conforming to that surface so it's
interesting when we look at a very
special animal like the gecko and you
can see it climbing on surfaces without
having to do this wrapping around and
holding on to different um like objects
in fact um what we see here is a gecko
holding on upside down to a flat piece
of glass um and it's doing it really
well and we wanted to understand how
it's able to do this so we had to take a
closer look um at its
toes and what we found um when looking
into this is there are two main
principles behind how this works that I
will focus on um for the sake of today
the first is called Vander wal's forces
and the second is called Contact
splitting for Vander wal's forces these
are weak forces on the um um on the
atomic level that uh basically come up
when the atoms get really close to each
other so we're talking sub um 10
nanometers um and you get this these
attractive forces between them so that's
like what has been identified as the
driving force for the gecko being able
to have these uh adhesive properties on
surfaces the other thing that's
important to note is called Contact
splitting so imagine you have a scenario
where you have um a hemisphere like this
and you have some amount of contact area
a if I take this contact area and then I
split it or sorry this contact area
requires some amount of force to be able
to detach from the surface there's some
type of act or adhesive adhesive energy
that that is existing there that we need
to then apply some amount of force to
detach if we take this area and then
split it up
across n hemispheres we now need a new
force to be be able to detach and in
fact this force is going to be larger um
and this basically comes down to uh
mitigating crack propagation um and now
you have to sort of um detach a lot of
different contact points at the same
time to get this this catastrophic
failure and this is uh an interesting
thing that what happens here is so the
more we split the context the more
adhesion we get but it becomes more
challenging to guarantee that we're
still making the same amount of contact
area with the other surface and so how
does the gecko do this um the way that
it makes sure to get this contact is by
having this hierarchy of structures on
its toe so if we zoom in um down all the
way to the nanometer scale we can see it
kind of branches to little uh Lamay and
C on the gecko sto and that helps it
conform to irregularities in the
surfaces that it's trying to climb on
making Mak sure it keeps that area of
contact there to get that Vander wal's
Force um and maintain its its
adhesion so you know we thought this was
cool and um Mark's lab over over the
years developed uh a material that can
do something like the gecko uh and it's
called gecko inspired dry adhesive it's
made up of well it's silicon rubber but
it has these tiny micro features that
look like uh tapered micro edges and
what happens um when you load these
features in sheer is that they start to
lay down and the contact area increases
so you get more adhesion so it's
controllable and so what I have here is
a sample of this gecko adhesive and I
can touch it it's not sticky it's made
of rubber when I place it onto a surface
and I Shear it it can do stuff like this
and you will say oh I can do that with
duct tape but you can't really do this
with duct tape so it's controllable it's
not sticky which means it doesn't need a
lot of energy into the system to detach
which is useful um for some
applications so what I did um during my
work here is I um studied the
manufacturing process quite a bit when I
started to understand how we can make
this material how we can maybe scale it
make it um more accessible and
understand what goes into successful
manufacturing of that which if you have
questions about that you can ask me
after um the presentation but more
importantly I also looked at once we
have the material how can we ensure that
we get good uh surface confirmation like
what the gecko does except you know in
this case we maybe don't have a
sophisticated system like the
gecko uh so um you know throughout my
research I looked at different length
scales that we have to address uh in
order to achieve good contact area but
for today I'd like to focus on one of
the projects that I worked on which
involves how to effectively use the
adhesive in a robotic setting where you
have a single arm picking operation and
you have limited exposure of the target
object so you have maybe access to one
surface of the target object um and how
can we use the adhesion effect
effectively perhaps with some more
traditional robotic grippers that we've
seen so the motivation for the for this
project like I said is you have a
limited working area so let's assume you
don't have a box and you have two sides
and you're coming in and trying to pick
it up on both sides you have one face
that's exposed to
you the other thing is that there's no
guarantee here of what the surface is
going to look like um because we're
dealing with maybe a wide array of
objects we're trying to pick up so they
might be not flat
deformable um you know what have you and
and mostly we're looking at um mesoscale
length scale which is is basically on
the millimeter scale and this scenario
is a good way to describe a task that we
all do very often which is perhaps
grocery shopping uh and we're we're good
at this task so it's a single arm
manipulation task with a variety of
objects that are all um have different
uh surface properties and they're all
tightly packed which means there's only
one face that's exposed to us to deal
with usually and like I said we're
really good at this but then if you put
a robot here it's not maybe as good as a
human at doing this but the problem is
the same you have a single arm
manipulation task with a wide variety of
objects that are all tightly
packed and uh in the literature and in
Industry some of the more common robotic
tools that we use are the suction tool
and the parallel jaw
gripper but when you think about only
have one having one exposed face you you
immediately go to oh we probably need a
suction tool here because we don't have
parallel faces of an object that we can
come in with a parallel jaw gripper and
grab so that's why we're focusing more
on on that tool but what happens when
you introduce an interesting uh
challenging um you know variety of
objects that the suction tool cannot
pick up because they're heavy they're um
deformable which means you can't get a
get get a good seal um with the tool and
um some um places in Industry you you
see solution here where you have like a
big array of suction cups they come in
from the top and they can they can
handle um you know different packaging
and different bulky items but what we
notice here is they are coming in from a
top grasp and you have a very large area
that you're working with versus this
specific task we're coming in from the
side and we have less exposed area to
work with and so we start to see failure
modes that look like the one in the top
where the suction Chuck cup just can't
can't pick up the items so the question
is how can we leverage maybe um some of
the benefits of suction cups um but also
augment them with um the gecko adhesive
that we have that can provide good
Synergy and how can we make sure that
it's conforming and giving us uh good
surface confirmation in these in these
spaces so as any good mechanical
engineer will tell you the first thing
you want to do is figure out what your
free body diagram for the system looks
like basically we want to understand
what failure modes we might experience
when we're dealing with this task so
purely just a suction cup um this is a
very simplified Tod representation of
what's happening it's more complicated
than that but for the sake of
understanding what's going on if you
come in just with a section cup and try
to pick up an object such as this you
experience something uh that we call
appealing failure where the object
twerks twists off the front surface of
the section code okay well you can say
we can solve this problem by adding um a
reaction point that stops IT from
rotating off the front surface of uh the
suction cup sure so we added that um and
now we have um some leverage there to
stop the torquing failure but then what
happens is you don't have enough Force
to counteract the weight of the object
and so you slip off the surface so
that's another failure mode these could
happen at the same time but this is
generally what we're dealing with and to
address that well we add some upward
Force like say or dry adhesion um in a
very simple critical function prototype
here to show if this principle will even
work and in fact it works quite
well um but it's not enough to slap uh
flexible film onto uh an acrylic piece
like that we want to give it a little
more thought to make it more robust so a
new material that we introduced with the
manufacturing process of the gecko
adhesive is called Rip stop which is
used in making um camping gear so pretty
tough tear resistant super flexible um
and that's what we see uh over here so
it's basically nylon fibers and it's
inextensible along the direction of the
fibers um and we can cast Silicon onto
it because it is um silicon coated as
well and how do we make how do we make
sure this makes contact with the surface
of our objects a simple but very
effective way is giving it a a steady
stream of air flow so essentially a fan
um because you want compliance and what
more what is more compliant than a
stream of air so um what happens here
and I'll I'll try to play this video
again is that once the object is it
gonna play again no yeah it is uh once
the object makes contact with the film
and it becomes taught that's where you
see the engagement happening that's
where the adhesion is starting to take
place and um bringing this all together
we don't want to sacrifice the
performance of the suction cup which can
actually do a really good job with
smaller items lighter items things that
are not deformable um so we made uh a
gripper that can deploy when needed to
assist the suction cup when picking up
specific items um and so this is a very
you know mechanical solution here
there's one Servo motor things are
deploying locking into place fans
turning on with a limit switch basically
the setup this linkage setup is so that
any force from the object doesn't close
um what you've deployed but you can
still um retract everything with that
single Servo command again so it's
trying to limit as much complications
with um integrating into like you know
the software side of the robot which if
we can do that why not um understanding
how this works how this improves our
performance um we look at two far ends
of the uh of the spectrum here which is
on Rigid surface
um we see that the way the low chairing
is happening is after in this case about
seven Newtons of load on the suction cup
it begins to deflect and that's when
your adhesive starts to take off some of
that load um and you can see a linear
Trend the more weight we add into the
setup the more that's being held up by
the adhesive but it's interesting
because that's not exactly what's
happening in deformable more um
deformable objects like like bags um um
we we see here that it's uh the suction
cup is able to sort of pull in that that
bag surface more um and this causes a
different Trend in how the low chairing
is happening but in the end um you know
you get to the point where the excess
weight that's being added is still being
taken out by the adhesive um
so uh in addition to this though uh
another interesting thing we learned is
has to do with timing so you can affect
how soon you begin to load your adhesive
by adding some type of preload in your
grass planning strategy uh so basically
if you're worried that your suction cup
is going to fail and you really don't
want to load it so much in that
direction you add you come in in a way
and preload the adhesive before you
start lifting um before you you take off
the object off the of the Shelf uh and
start loading your suction cup um and
that what that does essentially is
shifts that linear Trend back so you're
loading the suction cup less early
basically um overall the performance of
the tool um was improved by 2 and A2
fold uh for more rigid objects but when
it comes to deformable things it went it
was binary it was like it didn't work
and then it did work because you were
going from not being able to get a seal
to having something that um uh helps the
suction cup so much that it can now
actually pick up the items and uh what's
cool is that we got to uh test this on a
uh robot that was developed by Toyota
Research Institute and here are some of
the different items that we were able to
pick up using this tool that the robot
couldn't pick up previously with just a
suction cup tool um and I will show you
a few videos of some of the highlights
that I think are the most um uh fun ones
to look at uh across a variety of
objects so the first one is a um
cardboard box here uh quite heavy
um of it's a box of trash bags but um
basically what you see on the left is
the suction cup failing to pick up the
box and then the new Tool uh being able
to to handle it uh quite effectively so
this is for a rigid object um and then
next uh the other object we see is a bag
of powdered sugar which is still heavy
pretty deformable um and quite a
challenge for suction cffs and you can
see here here how much adding that um
alleviation of of weight is helping uh
with the gripper and then uh finally it
was our white whale basically of this
pack nine pack bag of toilet paper which
it's exciting because it's heavy and
it's pretty deformable not a lot of
tools can do this with just that front
face being exposed and it does a pretty
good job of doing that as
well um so for me this was my at least
the project that I was most excited
about that I was very interested in
working on uh in my most recent project
uh throughout the PHD um if you have
more questions uh about this or some of
the other projects I've worked on I'd
love to answer them uh thank you all so
much for listening uh and I hope this
was
insightful and if anyone wants to play
with this you certainly can yeah
goe so I wanted to know using the reward
when you you are trying to grasp objects
how are you actually locating those
objects and how are you deciding the
point of contact with your rer which
should be the
St totally yeah that's a good question
so this is a so this is a project where
you have a whole team working on it
basically they built the robot from the
ground up and so you have a team that's
doing more of the controls and a team
that's doing more of the the hardware um
but what I can tell you from what I
learned uh working with this team is
basically you have um prior knowledge of
items in your inventory basically and so
you can um so you have information about
the weight and the location of the
center of mass of the object and for the
strategy for picking items in this case
was to situate the suction cup um as
close to the top edge of the item um as
one could get safely um to mitigate any
you know unwanted torquing um in that
scenario uh and let me think so part of
how you um in this case they were trying
to maintain the pose of the item and
always keep it as it is on the Shelf so
it made it easier to to make sure that
the adhesive was being loaded the whole
time um but I think if we went a step
further and wanted to to load things
like uh more controllably load the
adhesive first we can try to adjust the
pose of the end affector more such that
you can come in at an angle load the
film first and then make contact with
the suction cup um and and you can get
more clever the strategies there but
this was like what's the simplest thing
we can get away with um to achieve
this yeah what's the requirement on the
surface qualities of your object for the
suction cup and the I mean the adesive
to be effective to be what effective uh
yeah so Geo adhesive works quite well
with smooth surfaces um um mainly
because the less you know dips and
valleys in your surface the more contact
area you get um so things that could be
more challenging um are something like
really rough cardboard but in the
scenario of the grocery store a lot of
the stuff is nice and laminated and
you've got nice pictures on everything
so it's a good application in this space
um but if you wanted to go further and
try to apply it to a more wider of of
things we've done um like combining it
with some interesting electrostatic
stuff to improve the contact area with
the objects but in this case if you're
just using the gecko of by itself it
does quite well with smooth surfaces uh
the suction cup does really well with
flat rigid surfaces because you can get
a good seal and in fact you could even
turn off your suction and hold that and
or turn off your vacuum and hold the
suction in place when it comes to
deformable objects you have to keep
running it to basically you're
continuously pulling it towards your
gripper um so those those are the
different considerations and um
effective like surfaces that we can use
this on did that answer your question
okay
yeah uh when you're doing the modeling
of the grass do you need to uh at all
model the stochasticity in the grass and
then follow up from that you have like
is there a way to kind of have
contingency plans if your first GR
does it
succeed that's an interesting question
uh that is a more of like a long-term
question and the team that's working on
this robot is always trying to make sure
that the throughput is higher every time
they iterate um personally I was not
working on the the grass planning myself
um but the idea is um you know get to
the point where it's G to work every
time which is you know it's a great goal
to have um but it would be a good idea
to maybe have like you said a backup
plan like what happens if something
slips how can we kind of recover from it
they're not implementing that at the
moment maybe they should um but you know
that's a that's a great Point um to
bring up for
sure cool are we good on time we're okay
yeah if we don't have any more questions
we can wrap up here's here our student
speaker is atin
[Applause]
J